ma fu fatto che non risuscito a crilin
ok
guarda tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su un
videogame veramente epico innanzitutto
ragazzi e tutto italiano c'è un progetto
italiano quindi anche le voci sono
italiane fantastico volevo iniziarlo con
voi perché secondo me fa morire dal
ridere ho visto un paio di nuovo in giro
facciamo nuova partita visto che che si
parte tutti l'italiano dato mi fa
stranissimo dawa si chiama the wire rom
non avrà un angoletto il titolo the
wardrobe significa il guardaroba che
sarebbe questo dal quale esce uno
scheletro che sarei cyber protagonista
la partenza è da dieci complimenti per
essere partito che tanto non si sa
perché siamo usciti in un armadio sopra
una pila di rifiuto dei getti marmocchi
mica che in italia non orgasmo ragazzi
migliori del sì dopo tutto bene
ragazzino lo tiene tra chi è questo o la
caduta che forse ho usato la lingua è
uno scheletro non so se i problemi fuori
a calci tratto quella è una pagina dello
slider man e la specie di discarica
armadio in una discarica a perché tu
vivevi nell'armadio
conosco l'indirizzo della nuova casa di
roma il problema sarà farci arrivare
l'armadio ok
spiegami perchè mirino perché sei lo
scheletro nell'armadio
un modo per tirarlo non è vero c'è chi
incontri con te no gioco dell'anno no
vabbè tanto questo non è un volantino
zio alla pagina dei lander nuccio dietro
devo tirare giù l'armadio ragazzi a ok
possa interagire
vorrei proprio vedere the anti martin
gaza lo zio che rachitico dei miei
stivali ma sotto stai calmo è più magro
di me che cazzo vuoi devo entrare qui
dentro si per forza malvezzi minuti su
spediva tutti quella il trono di spade
sentito sotto il collo sai questo numero
bellissimo no vabbè fermi questo e
quello dei due fantagenitori chomp il
sindaco questa ilbo luca di crash
bandicoot quella è la mandragola di
harry potter
ok facciamo tipo neville paciock veniamo
di svenire stridula mi fa accapponare la
pelle
meglio non combinare disastri e qui
intorno flaviani con cto dire stai
parlando
ogni giocatore dall'altra parte dello
schermo signore l'esecutore schermo
trasformato due anni la migliore verso è
stato più grandi più vasto si chiama aku
aku io avrò mai chiamato a qualcuno
chiamava bukhan a caso la nazione non
volete decidermi a sviluppare un nuovo
trash bene coi ragazzi abbiamo capito
che non ci aiuta il tipo stronzo quindi
altri che diceva sulla specie sul
ginocchio
posso prenderlo è infatti a mi chiamavo
visto devono essere le chiavi della
gruppo e come con la telecinesi è che ne
so frate o esso ci sto provando devo
distrarlo in qualche modo ragazzi come
faccio
via diario di tom reeve avrei voluto
vedere come te la saresti cavata se
questo or craxi fosse stato un nokia 33
facciamone una religione di questo
videogioco no seriamente qualcuno crei
una religione su questa roba ragazzi
devo aprire la gru con le chiavi devo
capire come prender le chiavi però che
non ho ancora capito la possa aprire a
posso uscire meglio aspettare che faccia
buio quando i ragazzi si sarà perché ti
vuoi mimetizzare tra quelli che crescono
per halloween perfetto di el'apporto
niente non devo fare un cazzo che come
lo tirò giù un armadio mediamente
l'obiettivo di questo videogame e
portare giù l'armadio e tornare acqua un
marchio all'americana c'è stato addio
traslocata vero mai immaginato con
vedere pinhead con i boxer a cuoricini
chi effettivamente non avevo il massimo
però a questa è una casa sull'albero
posso andare sopra giorno tanto c'è un
gatto che ha buttato giù una statua è la
misurazione più strana che abbia mai
visto
cioè cucirsi la barbas una casa
sull'albero ha proprio fatto che non
risuscito a crilin ok ragazzi non ho
capito che cosa mi serva l'eremita
chiesta tizia c'è una tizia salve io
posso parlare col quota becco perché sei
così arrabbiato sopra è chiuso e non
possiamo fare ha detto sul serio regali
circostanze mi presterò da interprete la
camera al piano no capricciosa di un
regno e la mia ragazza non possiamo
appartarci per amoreggiare un poco e lo
stupido giorni muscolo ostacola
morettino shaw cuore così a johnny bravo
ora è allo stremo palestrato di giorni
si è chiuso in camera con la morettina
di facili costumi in trambus e news
visto che non puoi andare di sopra
perché non mi dai una mano a portare lo
trovate
mi mandavano sicuro il diavolo
scherzavo e si trovasse un modo per
liberare la stanza d'accordo a ok che
non muoverti di qua e non abusare di lei
fino al ritorno non lo so niente devo
liberare la stanza perché sono questo
qua a busta della ragazza devo andare di
sopra quindi andiamo lì sopra donnie
darko e matrix tutti e due insieme non a
farmi parlare colpisce ti prego non ha
un aspetto non esattamente rassicura ma
fottitene musica a tutto volume e gente
che balla oh sees pronzati birra molto
originale vabbè mi fate parlare colpe
dove rodio e vaffanc scegli tu gli sto
video vince qualsiasi cosa di j
comunque a parte morpheus e tutti quanti
e dovevo andare di sopra tutti c'è anche
la cucina una femmina azione
oddio se l'olandese volante in cui si
apre a posso aprire il frigo fatemi
aprire il frigo fermi natio angry birds
dentro un game boy fresato è passo alla
fine sei stato tu a fare la fine del
maialino in agrodolce a caso è vero a
parte il fatto che i magneti di the
trees sono epici assenzio ho preso anche
l'assenza mica boogie man a madame e
autore di questo videogioco
d'ora in avanti puoi contare sul mio
odio incondizionato casco da master
chief
lo fai prendere canicola ma stage e
master chief
no non sto parlando del talent chi cazzo
del crac casa il casco di craco mi conta
l'ho presa ok perfetto cervello
finalmente trovato cosa regalarti per il
prossimo compie grande fratello effetto
lo prendo come un complimento non ci
mancava almeno di tanto vabbè ogni tanto
ti prometto ci posso provare però non te
lo assicuro è ma ci provo da una
polaroid usare il flash dio mio così lo
illumini le quinte che se offerte ci
sarà un limite alle p cita delle cose
non può essere infinita di che a ripreso
a male ci vediamo alla prossima cosa
cazzo è servito non è un'idea
pronunciamo l'ho trovata una bambola
gabella bombola servirà qualcosa devo
andare di sopra perché cesta quello che
sta faccio un batman con la tipa e
sarebbe lui il ragazzo alticcio ragazza
il gip del pappagallo che ripete le cose
quindi ha sentito questa frase almeno
una volta non ha proprio un 6 la celebre
colò comitato nella zucca ma lei è un
problema fatemi entrare nella stanza
della cravatta appesa della maniglia più
dell'art ello di thor non aprite quella
porta
vabbè fallo che te frega il berretto
posso prenderlo perfetto cosa ho trovato
non ho capito cosa ho trovato capelli ma
va ragazzi bussiamo stavolta prima che i
marines innervosisce sempre quando busso
mentre in bagno non capisco perché
diventano tutti così scontrosi a usarla
ma a noi posso muovermi da fantastico
con la mappa tipo e muore veloce da una
parte all'altra ma io faccio ancora
qualcosa da fare niente non funziona un
cazzo la bambolina sul mac ha funzionato
non so perché senta non è che potrebbe
farmi una cortesia
ok esserti di una qualche utilità
volentieri potrebbe cucirmi
sulla testa di questa abbandona cosa per
quale motivo secondo il quale gli va
bene per quale motivo spiegano cosa sta
succedendo
ma cosa vuoi fare non ho capito cosa
vuoi fare se non ho capito cos'è bambola
voodoo cosa cosa mi serve la bambola
forme non so che ci sono anche me la fa
tra fare ho dei problemi con la mia
bambola avuto una eco mica sociali della
vittima e gli ovociti su questa pigotta
ma senza risultati
che devo fare riposizionare la bambola
al centro di un pentacolo ecco voglio
usare il mio col bianchissimo gli occhi
rievoca pensieri negativi che hanno per
protagonista la vittima testimoniata
grande frater a questo devo sentirmi
dire che abbiamo fatto la gara non so
come ma ha funzionato la bambola
pensieri negativi che si sta sforzando
proprio insieme cos'è quindi ma che
cazzo sto facendo quindi era veramente
giorni lo sapevo io lo sapevo ci avrei
scommesso tutto era johnny bravo su
sempre tanto sul birillo le hanno
infilzato fantastico geniale grazie ai
fratelli sapete perché dopo giorni bravo
cosa ci avevano contro giorni bravo
frate e poi andare a scopa torneo da
letto al piano di sopra e libera come
promesso parati fa come se i delegati
subito la bontà totti fermo immobile
siamo subito la banda quale motti che
cosa sto guardando di con i ragazzi
andate alla discarica ma sa mettere una
frase in piedi pieni attraverso pd cosa
che facevo forme perdere tempo giusto
quindi possiamo andare risoluto
ai stanza tutto pronto perfetto a suo
vantaggio se non riuscivano più a
trattenersi amica a sto punto potranno
farlo con l'eremita lì sopra volendo
però ognuno ha il suo modo di fare prima
questa sarebbe una panda il basso lo
smilzo e il grosso sembra è doppia tv ed
è detti proveranno quello è la testa di
alien sarebbe quel modo per farlo
scendere ti aiuteremo rischieremo di
certo lo so del collo per te le chiavi
non me le dà al tizio ci ho provato non
so quante volte ma porca eva ma che ne
so io assenzio ne dà la paga con la pala
prendi la clava la co2 taglia in testa
la partita no serio veramente ma come
marco rodio vice amico in modo non avevo
altra scelta
no non ha un'altra mai fatto bene perché
le riforme come un angioletto
noi abbiamo fatto tutto il bordello con
l'alcol per cosa che alla fine c'era una
pala grazie grazie e molto gentile
usciamo di qua per l'amor di dio ci
abbia messo una vita in mezzo per questa
cosa ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi non so
come ma con le chiavi dovremmo riuscire
ad aprire la porta ora santo iddio
quanto tempo ok mancava anche fallout in
sto videogame mancava solo quello hai
già fatto a mio zio non so che cosa sto
facendo vado a caso a ok si gira a posto
quindi modo devo andar giù
sì ma chi è una vita e mezza per fare
sta cosa ragazzi non ci posso credere
quanto che per una minchia dall'armadio
potevi tipo arrampicarti e spingerlo
giorno bene senti basso ho fatto e poi
non pronto possiamo procedere perfetto
che ho detto ragazzi
muoviamoci oddio che è successo però più
se chiuso alla fine ma non è vero a
perché finita la demo mette il ragazzo
di scritta o e questa è la demo è finita
no perché al ragazzo che ho incluso
l'episodio della la demo di the wardrobe
che arriva fino a questo punto era solo
una demo non è un gioco completo io non
ho però a parte il finale che magari a
scrittina però per il resto non ho
parole in kong col des not valeva tutto
il gioco cioè solo per quello ma solo
per quello vale la pena prenderlo propri
20 ragazza perché è stato fatto né degli
italiani quindi dio mio veramente
complimenti
voglio lasciarmi link ragazzi nella
descrizione per supportare il progetto
perché dio mio
lo voglio completo sto videogame
assolutamente lo farò spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa se il servizio è
piaciuto al trattamento è un mi piace il
tasto mi piace non deve esistere più
dove veramente cliccato troppe volte che
su questo video che merita la vita che
qualsiasi documento è un mi piace al
capo ciani facebook e con i video
straten descrizione si scambiavano con
servito dai ragazzi